bonsoir mesdames et messieurs alors la
ville va finalement déversés 8 milliards
de litres d'eaux usées directement dans
le fleuve plus tard ce mois ci une
procédure exceptionnelle rendue
nécessaire à cause des travaux de
réaménagement de l'autoroute bonaventure
françois cormier une procédure qui fait
aussi beaucoup jaser on a parlé hier
avec daniel green entre autres
s'inquiète pas mal de monde mais la
ville dit qu'elle n'a pas le choix
effectivement parce que vous savez
patrice dionne chute à neige sous
l'autoroute bonaventure et on refait
bonaventure donc on doit déplacer cette
chute à neige en créer une nouvelle
pour créer cette chute à neige il faut
envoyer des employés faire des travaux à
l'intérieur de la chute qui se trouve au
dessus d'un égout alors pour que les
employés ne souffre pas d'émanations
toxiques il faut absolument arrêter le
passage de tout ce qui à l'intérieur de
cette grande conduire le problème c'est
que la conduite effet 30 kilomètres donc
c'est pour cette raison pour le 18
octobre pendant sept jours
on va déverser un lait une partie donc
des égouts de montréal du contenu des
égouts de montréal dans le fleuve on
parle de 8 milliards de litres pendant
sept jours
ça aura des conséquences évidemment
notamment la contamination
microbiologique dans le fleuve à partir
de la chine jusqu'à pointe aux trembles
et partout en aval la ville de montréal
écoutez on n'avait pas le choix il n'y
avait pas d'autres techniques possibles
on a fait tout ce qui était possible
comme études et c'est vraiment cette
technique leur qu'il faut utiliser ce
qui déçoit évidemment une partie des
gens qui utilisent le fleuve saint
laurent
je vous laisse les entendre suis vice
président du comité exécutif de montréal
et chef de l'opposition sur ses plates
un peu en même temps et c'est la seule
façon je passe au sein de l'association
mais
est ce que tout le monde trouve ça pas
mal plate
ça fait deux semaines que j'ai commencé
ici a été sauf que j'étais un peu triste
mais j'aimerais pouvoir continuer un
petit peu plus longtemps on avait eu une
seule option différente on l'aurait dit
on n'a pas d'option différents et c'est
là qu'il faut regarder
il n'a pas d'options différentes pour un
événement de cette importance là où est
le maire de montréal sur l'avait annoncé
qu'il y avait une troisième troisième
match préparatoire de baseball au stade
olympique
il serait présent pour faire cette
annonce alors justement mai où le maire
de montréal le maire était à
drummondville aujourd'hui avait une
réunion de l'union des municipalités du
québec et parlant des municipalités il
ya des mères qui se plaignent de cette
décision d'un montréal entre autres le
maire de sorel-tracy qui est inquiet
pour les concerts les conséquences
environnementales pour sa ville le maire
de trois-rivières qui dit on a donné la
permission à montréal mais les autres
villes jamais ne pourrait bénéficier
d'une telle permission je vous laisse
entendre donc donc ces élus suivi de
dénis coderre dans le moment nous les
gentils sorel tracy ce qu'on veut pas
c'est devenir le champ d'épuration de la
ville de montréal sont prêts les 8
milliards de litres qui vont être servis
durant cette journée là c'est comme s'il
avait toujours gardé verserait pendant
114 jours
c'est logique et quand même presque 4
moore de déversement ça serait ce qu'un
abattoir bière freins des versements cio
barak a tenu à leur instinct mauvaise
séjour rapport aussi là pour pour pour
certains mais tout est suivi tout est
encadré
donc patrice à partir du 18 octobre
pendant une dizaine de jours le les
travaux ces sept jours mais pendant une
dizaine de jours et sera interdit de se
baigner devrait faire trop froid mais de
faire du kayak aussi de faire du sur la
pêche donc tout ce qui ferait en sorte
que vous pouvez entrer en contact avec
l'autre c'est la dernière grille nous
disait hier même le sait pas vos chiens
et jouer dans l'eau du fleuve parce qu'
ils vont ce flou chez après puis l'eau
contaminée peut ça peut être dangereux
c'est pas c'est malsain damas une
évidence très bien merci
il ya une semaine françois au revoir